careful wordsmiths mind where you step
this word's been
contaminated yes
contam innate it's a verb it means to
make something dirty or unsafe you can
think of it as another word for pollute
but it can also mean something's been
added that shouldn't be there like if
you have a peanut allergy and there's
some peanut butter on a piece of bread
that bread has been contaminated with
peanut it's been compromised toss it get
it into containment the derivation for
this word is relatively straightforward
I think so there's con meaning with or
together Tang or tacted meaning touching
uh Tam right in contaminate is a
modified form of Tang which is Latin for
to touch no Liang don't touch me and
eight which turns other words into verbs
into action words so when we talk about
contamination things touching together
that shouldn't be touching I want you to
imagine a person who doesn't like it
when different Foods touch on their
plate maybe that's you maybe you're that
person and you don't like it when the
rice touches the soag paneer or the
mashed potato touches the peas or the
plantains touch the beans whatever it
may be now there's Bean Essence on my
plantains they've been contaminated by
beans they've touched the beans this is
not a problem for me noted Bean lover
David rystrom but contaminate has a
negative meaning it's not just touching
right it has this connotation of ruining
something or messing it up let's come up
with some words that use those word
Parts con and tang and tacted I'll give
you 10 seconds we'll put on some music
and then we'll come back and discuss
ready
[Music]
okay contact which is almost exactly the
same as contaminate but without that
negative meaning this just means to
touch right you can reach reach out to
someone and contact them by talking to
them or you can literally touch them
shake their hands get skin-to-skin
contact tangible which is an adjective
meaning touchable or real what are the
tangible effects of a plan what are its
real world impacts it's the opposite of
abstract it's another way of saying
concrete uh a tangible thing is physical
real and crucially touchable intact
which means unharmed literally untouched
not touched if a box full of ceramic
mugs falls from a shelf and none of them
break they are miraculously intact they
were not affected not touched by the
fall but let's get back to contaminate
though because I want to use it in a few
sentences so follow me to the next
screen we've got the verb form right and
there's the use where it's polluted or
wrong or bad the oil spill contaminated
the waters for miles in every direction
right that's that's obvious the oil is
is bad for the ocean the ocean is now
contaminated by the oil spill the oil
shouldn't be there right that's the
straightforward use but we can also use
it jokingly or in an exaggerated way let
me demonstrate with the noun form of
this word contamination I cannot abide
this contamination someone has put mint
in my lemonade and I must tell you
wordsmiths that is in my mind a fabulous
combination most people would not
consider that to be a contamination but
there you go that's contaminate think of
an oil spill wow that's a sentence I
hate saying okay let me get out of here
before I do any more damage even to a
theoretical ocean uh you can learn
anything daveid out